how's it goin everybody it's Warren and
we have a huge potential spoiler for
Avengers in game today through official
Avengers in-game merchandise this is
coming directly from Hasbro so it is
official and it's already on the shelves
of some stores and this is a really big
spoiler if you do not want to know
anything about Avengers in game you
should click away now also if you'd like
to enter my giveaway I'm giving away a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and a
painting of fan oohs by globe I bow all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain ok if
you're still with me today we had a toy
that was released that is of another
Infinity Gauntlet as you can see this is
obviously not the original Infinity
Gauntlet that Eitri forged at Netta
Valier but it is an Infinity Gauntlet
nonetheless we can see that it has all
of the stones in it we can also see that
it has a little bit of red in it as well
so that leads us to believe that this is
an Infinity Gauntlet that Iron Man will
make an Avengers end game this has been
a rumor and also mass speculation that
has been going around for a very long
time now either the Avengers cannot
defeat Thanos to get the Infinity
Gauntlet from him or the Infinity
Gauntlet is damaged and no longer works
so the Avengers figure out a way to
forge their own Infinity Gauntlet there
are a few ways this could happen they
could use vibranium from Wakanda that
could possibly be strong enough to hold
the Infinity stones or Thor could simply
go back to neduvaali r-e tree could
possibly still be alive and could help
thor craft a new Infinity Gauntlet or
Thor could take Tony Stark to Nettie
vollar
and Tony could forge his own one to go
with this suit there are a number of
different ways that the Avengers could
form their own Infinity Gauntlet but
this toy League does seem to confirm
that they will try it one way or another
now although this toy is official and it
is on shelves right now it may not
appear in the movie and the Russo
brothers said that 99% of the time the
toy leaks aren't accurate but this is
not a leak these are literally being
sold at stores right now but last year
there was official toys of the Hulk
busting out of the Hulkbuster armor
which we never saw happen in Avengers
infinity war so there is a slim chance
that this may not be in the movie but
why make a toy of another Infinity
Gauntlet this could be misdirection but
it does seem like the theories are true
Tony Stark and the Avengers will forge
their own Infinity Gauntlet in Avengers
endgame this makes a lot of sense
because we do not see the Infinity
Gauntlet on Thanos in the trailers that
we've seen him instead we see him with
his armor on and a massive double bladed
sword it has already been confirmed that
in Avengers endgame Thanos took off his
armor when he got more than one Infinity
stone because he believed that he didn't
need it anymore he was too powerful to
use it so now he puts back on his armor
is it because the Infinity Gauntlet and
the Infinity stones no longer work it
appears to be that way and that could be
why the Avengers have to forge their own
Infinity Gauntlet because the one that
Thanos had no longer works but let me
know what you all think about this do
you think that we'll see this Infinity
Gauntlet in the movie do you think the
Avengers forge their own let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and again don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers
endgame and Marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]